Hey guys, something seems to be just wrong
with Tulsi Gabard.
Tulsi gabber is a Congresswoman from Hawaii
who is running for president.
She's pulling about 0.8% right now in an average
of
recent polls, and she put out this total grand
standing video about how she might be boycotting
tonight's fourth democratic presidential debate,
a pre announcement that she may have a further
announcement to make about boycotting the
debate if she decides to, I'm not even gonna
play the video itself because it's such cringe-worthy
grand standing, but you can find the video
online.
But here's the tweet where she posts the video
saying, I am seriously considering boycotting
October 15 debate to bring attention to DNC.
Corporate media's effort to rig 2020 primary,
not against Bernie this time, but against
voters in early States, Iowa, New Hampshire,
and presumably South Carolina.
So Tulsi is announcing that she may have a
boycott to announce first.
She complained that the standards were unfair
for the third debate, which she didn't make,
right.
The standards unfairly kept her out of the
debate.
In reality, the standards for the third debate
were too low and the third debate ended up
being filled with people that have absolutely
no chance of winning the nomination.
Now she makes the fourth debate qualifies
for the fourth debate and she might boycott,
but instead of just announcing a boycott,
she announces that she's considering a boycott.
It's the most boring attention, trolling and
grandstanding, and it's stunning that her
followers are actually seeing this as principal.
The end sort of powerful in some bizarre way.
I looked around a little bit at comments about
her pre announcement announcement and the
Tulsi sycophants are just titillated by this
video and the threat to boycott the DNCs rules
have nothing to do with her having no chance
at this nomination.
She never had a shot.
She plays coy with Republican framing of the
issues.
She plays this enlightened centrist role.
It's all so boring and this is such a desperate
attention seeking move.
No one other than her sycophants is even paying
attention to her campaign and reducing the
number of people on the stage tonight would
be a good thing.
I hope she boycotts the debate.
I don't think she will but it would make the
debate more watchable and maybe we would allow
us to learn a little more about the positions
of the candidates that actually have a shot
and he or she is sort of threatening to boycott
but not just saying I'll boycott it.
Never mind that it would be much more useful.
I mean listen, if I were her and I had this
position about how it's all rigged again and
I'll address that in a second.
I think the best thing to do would be show
up at the debate and talk during the debate
about how you believe it to be rigged.
Right.
Rather than a Twitter video where you talk
about, you might subsequently announced that
you were boycotting it because as you see
it, it is rigged.
I hope she does boycott just to get her off
the stage.
Uh, but I don't think that she's going to.
Now as far as the DNC is a bad actor, of course,
of course the DNC is a bad actor.
They were a bad actor in 2016 this year.
They're allowing networks to run these debates
in this horrible for-profit pandering game
show like away, I can't stand where the first
question often doesn't even get asked until
like 25 minutes into the debate.
But the requirements aren't strict enough.
Stricter requirements would reduce the number
of people on stage.
They would get us more speaking time for the
people that actually have a shot.
We're just a few months from the first votes
being cast and it would be great to actually
clear the stage a little bit, but there are,
uh, you know, there, there are plenty of criticisms
that you can make of the DNC, but Tulsi is
polling at 0.8%.
No one cares if she boycotts and quite frankly
I hope that she does in order to give the
people who have a shot more speaking time
because I want to hear from them in depth
their understanding of an ideas about how
to solve the pressing issues of our day.
If you really want to criticize the DNC, go
to the debate, criticize it during the debate
instead of this pre boycott announcement that
you may be boycotting at some point in the
future.
I know people are going to, some people are
going to be upset with me about this.
I know that the Tulsi sycophants are disproportionately
loud and they'll come in, they'll dislike
my YouTube video, and they'll leave comments
about, you know, I'm a DNC shill or this or
that or the other thing.
I don't care.
This is the most boring form of political
grandstanding and it is stunning, truly stunning
that there are people who are seeing this
as some kind of really big, important and
principled move from the powerful Tulsi gabber
gimme a break.
You're pulling 0.8% do whatever you want.
I hope you boycott, but I assume that you'll
be there.
We've been talking about this for years.